[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le journal
de tv 78 nous sommes le mercredi 2
octobre les titres de l'actualité locale
à 20 ans que ce club d'entreprises
oeuvre pour approcher le monde
économique et éducatif face yvelines
développe des actions pour favoriser
l'accès à l'emploi à la fondation va
célébrer son anniversaire demain au
théâtre national de saint quentin en
yvelines depuis la rentrée 98 résidents
ont pu intégrer ce foyer de jeunes
travailleurs la résidence marcel callo a
rouvert après trois ans de fermeture le
lieu géré par les apprentis d'auteuil
propose aussi un accompagnement à ses
habitants et puis troisième volet de
notre dossier consacré au cinéma dans
les yvelines le département qui a servi
de décor pour de nombreux tournages de
films français et internationaux zoom
dans cette édition
c'est inédit depuis 2001 les policiers
étaient dans la rue aujourd'hui à paris
à l'appel d'une intersyndicale 25 mille
manifestants selon les syndicats
mobilisation pour préserver leur régime
spécifique de retraite mais aussi sous
fond d'inquiétude en raison des
conditions de travail qui se dégradent
plus en plus de fonctionnaires
démissionnent ou pire en arrive au
suicide en un an dans les yvelines
quatre agents ont mis fin à leurs jours
dans le cortège parisien de nombreux
policiers des yvelines pour le 78
notamment nous montrent tous manifesté
sur paris pour le manque d'effectifs
il ya un grand manque d'effectifs sur le
département des yvelines
d'ailleurs depuis le week-end dernier on
peut voir que plus de la moitié des
effectifs de police secours du
commissaire adversaires sont en arrêt
maladie
nous avons des tâches indues qui
pourrissent le quotidien de nos
collègues faut savoir que la garde de la
lanterne sur versailles par exemple
mobilis trois véhicules tous les
week-ends de police secours il ya aussi
pour alerter l'opinion publique car il
faut savoir que la profession est
victime d'actes violents qui se banalise
on peut le voir aussi depuis deux
week-ends sur plaisir mes collègues sont
attaqués par des groupes d'individus et
c'est un phénomène qui est très
inquiétant
fin août le gouvernement a annoncé la
mise en place d'une expérimentation de
nouveaux cycles horaires pour les
policiers permettre par exemple aux
agents de bénéficier d'un week end sur
deux pour rester en famille
c'est notamment en raison des conditions
de travail dégradées qu'elle avait
justifié son geste dans une lettre le 23
septembre dernier une directrice d'école
a mis fin à ses jours en seine saint
denis
suite à cet acte un appel à la grève est
lancé pour la journée de demain jeudi
par plusieurs syndicats d'enseignants
des rassemblements sont prévus dans le
93 mais aussi dans les yvelines le snes
fsu appelle à une mobilisation devant
les locaux des inspections de
circonscription du département
quelques perturbations sont donc à
prévoir dans les établissements
scolaires pour les prévisions dans votre
commune rapprochez-vous de votre mairie
ou consulter son site internet
depuis 1999 le club et est engagée pour
favoriser l'accès à l'emploi face
yvelines à 20 ans un anniversaire qui
sera célébré demain soir au théâtre
national de saint quentin en yvelines
bonsoir franck ollivier bonsoir gars
vous êtes administrateur de facile une
ancien président aussi de la fondation
de 2008 à 2011 dans les yvelines face ça
veut dire fondation agir contre
l'exclusion en 20 ans ce credo n'a pas
changé non il n'a pas changé on s'est
quand même un petit peu centré sur deux
axes que sont la kz éducation et lax
emploi parce que ce sont les deux
principaux vecteurs d'exclusion sur
lequel nous nous sommes focalisés
comment vous êtes arrivé vous à vous
engager dans le fascine hors de moi
personnellement je suis dans une
entreprise qui est la caisse d'epargne
qui est membre fondateur de face et bien
entendu chaque collaborateur qui est
engagée en parlent à d'autres d'autres
collègues et forcément on y est
naturellement est ce que vous vous
garder un souvenir peut-être de votre
engagement ou aussi de votre présidence
vous avez été prises en 2008 à 2011 la
présidence c'est intéressant mais c'est
ce que surtout intéressant c'est ce que
l'on fait et moi j'ai un vrai souvenir
personnel
c'est lors d'un parrainage j'avais
parrainer une personne seniors que l'on
dit on le dit qu'ils étaient en fin de
droit est dit si je trouve pas du boulot
d'ici la fin de l'année bien je pourrai
plus payer mon loyer
je l'accompagné pendant six mois et la
veille de noël
cette personne m'appelle en me disant
bessaih et franck j'ai trouvé du boulot
je démarre en janvier
ben je vous assure que c'est un des plus
beaux cadeaux de noël que j'ai reçu
c'est aussi l'un des socles de phase iib
l'insee c'est le bénévolat ses salariés
qui s'engagent
oui absolument ça donne un sens à la vie
de chacun qui s'engagent chaque bénévole
trouve vraiment à développement
personnel en étant un militant en étant
engagés dans la fondation agir contre
eux avec aujourd'hui plus de 2000
salariés qui sont engagés en 2000 c'est
le nombre total de salariés qui se sont
engagés depuis à peu près 20 ans chaque
salarié donne à peu près 25 heures de
son temps par parents à part chacun par
engagement donc au bout du bout ça fait
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'heures au
service de la lutte contre l'exclusion
et l'ambition au travers de vos actions
s'est finalement rapproché le monde
économique et le monde éducatif
est ce que la passerelle entre les deux
restent compliquées aujourd'hui oui bien
sûr parce que c'est toujours très
compliqué d'associer le monde de
l'éducation le monde de l'entreprise qui
sont deux mondes qui sont pas tout à
fait sur le même registre mais à force
de travailler depuis plus de 20 ans
effectivement on arrive à avoir des
passerelles avoir des enseignants à
avoir des bénévoles d'entreprise qui
conversent entre eux au profit des
jeunes au profit de ceux qui bénéficient
d' d'action
comme par exemple une graine
d'entreprise et ça c'est super
intéressant pour les jeunes de voix
qu'est ce que l'on peut faire à quoi ça
sert de faire des études
à quoi ça sert d'avoir de l'éducation
c'est de trouver un emploi c'est de
trouver un développement dans
l'entreprise plusieurs actions notamment
les job academy vous pouvez retrouver de
nombreux reportages en sur notre site
internet tv 78 des actions qui ont
permis d'accompagner au final dix mille
personnes en 20 ans et ça du coup le
bilan il est positif dans 20 ans il est
très positif alors dix mille on peut
dire cinq mille demandeurs d'emploi puis
cinq mille scolaires
will be long il est positif puisque si
on prend juste l'accès à l'emploi
eh bien on a un taux de retour qui est
de 68% 68 % de personnes qui ont été
suivis par face trouvent un emploi un
emploi stable soit en cdi
et ça c'est le meilleur cas du monde
soit en cdd de plus de plus de six mois
ce qui permet déjà de se faire un cv
intéressant
vous allez bien moins important le suivi
c'est ça qui fait la force de phase iib
been au travers notamment de tuteurs qui
accompagne les demandeurs d'emploi oui
il y un contrat de parrainage que le
bénéficiaire est le parrain s'engage il
signe un contrat de parrainage qui est
d'un minimum de quatre mois pour aider
le demandeur d'emploi à trouver du
boulot
l'obus l'ambition pardon l'objectif pour
les pour les prochaines années
l'ambition de la fondation agir contre
l'exclusion des yvelines s'est trouvé de
plus en plus d'entreprises qui sont
bénévoles qui est ce qui accompagne qui
sont partenaires du club donc rejoignez
nous rejoignez vous les entreprises le
club face au profit des bénéficiaires
mais aussi au profit des salariés qui
s'engagent et qui trouve un
développement personnel en dehors de
l'aspect purement de l'entreprise
purement professionnel de l'entreprise
nous reste moins d'une minute demain
soir et donc de vos 20 ans au théâtre
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
comment va se dérouler cette fois quel
est le programme le programme il est il
est très très chargé d'abord
on a aux environ 350 personnes qui ont
répondu positivement à cette soirée
des élus des chefs d'entreprise des
bénéficiaires pour certains c'est
d'abord la proclamation de ce succès des
dix mille bénéficiaires depuis plus de
20 ans mais aussi beaucoup de
témoignages beaucoup de beaucoup
d'émotion dans ce qu'ils ont pu
bénéficier des des des services de face
oui merci franck olivier administrateurs
et ancien président de facilité et bon
anniversaire donc l'actualité les
informations pour ce club à retrouver
sur son site internet qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran
après trois ans de fermeture la
résidence marcel callo à versailles est
de nouveau accessible aux jeunes
travailleurs en difficulté une
réouverture grâce au diocèse de
versailles à emmaüs habitat et aussi aux
collectivités locales à l'inauguration
de ce site géré par la fondation des
apprentis d'auteuil s'est déroulée il ya
quelques jours marylène iapichino depuis
le 1er juin
antoine est installé dans ce logement
refait à neuf à versailles comprendre
aux gens ces relogements couple c'est
assez spacieux pour ce 26 mètres carrés
il paie 554 euros auxquels il faut
encore déduire les apl à loyer dérisoire
comparé au prix du marché
car antoine et son amie jessica on peut
intégrer un foyer jeunes travailleurs la
résidence marcel callo géré par les
apprentis d'auteuil elle a pu être
rénové après une fermeture de trois ans
à l'aide du diocèse de versailles
d'emmaüs habitat et des subventions des
collectivités territoriales pour les
investissements à m il fallait trouver 5
millions donc
nous ne les avons pas on a nous
contribue beaucoup en donnant les locaux
pour 45 ans à emmaüs habitat et à charge
pour lui de restaurer l'ensemble plus
qu'un logement la fondation apprentis
d'auteuil met à leur disposition trois
intervenants sociaux pour aider les
jeunes dans leur projet professionnel ou
leurs démarches administratives
le défi consolante l'ambition de ce
projet là avec mon espace politique
c'est une puce le soir prend du temps
pour se rencontrer échanger en trop et
pouvoir gagner en confiance
julien fait partie des 98 résidents de
18 à 25 ans du foyer jeunes travailleurs
originaires du sud de la france il a
souhaité monter à paris pour concrétiser
son projet musical
après être passé de canapé en canapé et
de sous location sous location il a pu
s'installer dans la résidence
c'est vrai qu'il ya une émulation en
fait au final parce qu'on se retrouve
tous à vouloir avancer dans la vie
et voilà on a on a ses chances qui nous
sont donnés par le foyer qui sont très
important de prendre grâce à la
stabilité du foyer julien a pu
développer son label de musique et
sortira son premier projet au mois de
février prochain
en bref une troisième commune des
yvelines prend un arrêté anti pesticides
après le père elvis est la mère des
vêtements qui est à l'origine de cette
décision dans un communiqué la maire
écologiste ghislaine ceni également
conseiller régional justifie cette
interdiction par le manque de prise de
décisions de l'état sur le sujet elle
estime que les collectivités doivent
s'engager dans la défense du vivant
l'élu qui pourrait prochainement passer
devant le tribunal administratif de
versailles en septembre il a jugé non
conforme l'arrêté pris à part la mère du
perray-en-yvelines celle des devis est
convoqué par l'instance ce vendredi
vitrine à casser cambriolages des délits
commis cet été à saint rémy les
chevreuse à l'origine des mineurs ils
arrivent dans la commune par bus
noctilien ou via le rer b certaines
vitrines ne sont toujours pas réparé à
ce jour le maire de la ville a rencontré
à ce sujet la ministre de la justice les
précisions de manon varaldo et rodolphe
blondel saint rémy les chevreuse ville
connue pour sa quiétude et ses commerces
de proximité mais depuis plusieurs mois
ils sont la cible de cambriolages et
dégradations de vitrines des
cambriolages parfois rudimentaire les
délinquants ont cassé la porte d'une
pharmacie de la ville avec des
casseroles d'autres vitrines ont été
brisées avec des pierres ces délits sont
commis la nuit à saint rémy les
chevreuse terminus du rer b par des
personnes se présentant comme mineur et
avait des jeunes qu'on essayait de
vouloir entrer dans la boutique ma porte
allez allez mortelle est hs en photo
change et le
ballon le global et une fois je suis
sorti donc il y avait avait le traiteur
était déjà dehors il y avait un voisin
sic avait alerté parce qu il l entend du
bruit aussi qui habite à côté de chez
moi donc après ils ont été interpellés
un peu plus tard par la police mais
après ils ont été jugés mais relâché
après la justice des mineurs oppose sur
un texte l'ordonnancé du 2 février 1945
le maire a rencontré la ministre de la
justice pour une révision de cette
ordonnance
en france le seuil d'âge de
responsabilité pénale n'est aujourd'hui
pas précisément fixée la ministre lui a
fait part de son futur code de justice
pénale des mineurs
elle prévoit d'instaurer le seuil à 13
ans en dessous de cet âge seules des
mesures éducatives seront prononcés
cette réforme ne sera mise en vigueur
que dans un an le 1er octobre 2020
premières préconisations quand ils sont
identifiés et qu'on connaît les pays
d'origine de travailler avec les pays
d'origine pour les renvoyer dans leur
famille
deuxième point traitaient mieux la
récidive il est une autre disposition
qui vise à mieux indemniser plus
rapidement les victimes pour que les
victimes qui attendent des fois jusqu'à
18 mois pour avoir gain de cause sur
l'organisation
cette fois fait sur un délai pour moi
autre point du futur code de justice
pénale des mineurs 20 centre éducatif
fermé pour mineurs vont être créés en
france
[Musique]
le dossier de la semaine consacrée au
cinéma dans les yvelines nous nous
intéressons ce soir au film qui ont été
à tourner sur notre territoire et ils
sont nombreux depuis des décennies des
réalisations françaises aux
superproductions hollywoodiennes focus
sur ses tournages près de chez vous avec
aurélie ans baby sitting
jean-philippe ou encore la haine ces
films ont en commun leur lieu de
tournage les yvelines nombreux sont les
réalisatrices et réalisateur à avoir
posé leur caméra dans notre département
parmi les villes les plus prisées
versailles
tout cela est ridicule tout cela madame
c'est vers ça en 2005 la réalisatrice
américaine sofia coppola choisi la ville
du roi soleil pour son film marie
antoinette
la plupart des scènes sont tournées au
petit trianon au hameau de la reine et
bien sûr au château dont la
privatisation coûte 300 mille euros
autres lieux plus insolites à être
régulièrement prisé par les équipes de
tournage l'hôtel du département pour sa
ressemblance notamment avec l'elysée
juillet 2017
olivier baroux investi les lieux pendant
quelques jours pour les tuche 3 bat sans
rancune ce président-là temps quand moi
je vous dis j'ai voté pour vous jeff
devient président la république donc
bien évidemment cette salle servait à
réunir les ministres et dans la salle du
conseil des ministres était juste à côté
il en avait fait la chambre à coucher
des deux c'est en 1989 que l'hôtel du
département a cueilli son premier
tournage avec l'opération corned beef de
jean marie poiré ou encore le film
l'assaut avec vincent elbaz en 2010 à
cette époque les lieux été cédé à titre
gracieux ce n'est que depuis 2018 que le
département a mis en place une
convention payante
en gros une journée de tournage ça
comprend donc trois jours
d'immobilisation parce que vous avez une
journée de montage une journée de
tournage et puis de trois heures de
démontage il faut compter trois mille
six cents euros
la gare de ben est également choisi pour
le film les tuche 3 elle représente la
gare de bouzols d'où le tgv part à
quelques kilomètres de là l'église
saint-martin de thoiry sert de décor
pour le film les visiteurs sorti en 1993
le département des yvelines déjà atteint
très beau département donc qui associe
le monde économique le monde
comment dire agricole donc c'est vrai
que c'est des paysages très variés avec
beaucoup de lieux historiques
je pense que c'est des centaines de
films qui ont été réalisés en partie
dans les villes si la majeure partie des
films tournés sont français quelques
scènes du dernier opus dans games ont
été réalisés en 2015 dans les yvelines
et direction le château de voisins a
senti larion près de rambouillet ce
domaine privé et la demeure du président
snow la roseraie ainsi que les
intérieurs sont visibles dans le film
désolé mesdames je peux pas vous laisser
passer les c'est la rentrée
j'en prends la responsabilité proximité
avec paris et richesse de ses paysages
et de son patrimoine autant d'arguments
qui font des yvelines une terre très
prisée pour les tournages de films et
puisqu'on parle de cinéma petit tour
dans l'une des salles du département
c'est notre sortie du mercredi vous la
connaissez ce soir direction le cinéma
les yeux d'elsa à saint-cyr-l'ecole la
programmation présentée au micro de
patrick jacques de dixmude au cinéma les
yeux d'elsa ce mois ci c'est le mois du
cinéma d'animation comme tous les ans au
mois d'octobre on fait des focus sur le
cinéma d'animation et cette année on a
décidé de faire un focus sur le cinéma
d'animation japonais comme on le fait
très souvent ou parce qu'en plus il ya
des films extrêmement importants qui
sont sortis les six derniers mois et on
n'avait pas eu l'occasion de les passer
donc vous allez pouvoir éventuellement
les revoir éventuellement les rattraper
on va vous diffuser pendant une toute
une partie du mois d'octobre les films
le mystère des pingouins
wonderland le royaume sans pluie et les
enfants de la mer avec en particulier le
samedi 19 octobre une soirée après midi
soirée animation qui commence à ses
heures et qui finira à 23h avec les
trois films que je viens de citer
chaque film à 3,060 si on organise cette
soirée c'est aussi parce que saint-cyr
comme l'année dernière organise un
concours de dessin manga et que le
samedi 19 octobre
on vous en dira plus dans la salle du
cinéma les yeux d'elsa
alors rendez vous nombreux pour
découvrir ces trois films l'un les deux
l'autre comme vous voulez en tout cas le
19 octobre vous pourrez découvrir ces
films qui ont qui ont été des très
grands succès et qui sont pour certains
issus de deux mangas extrêmement connue
à très bientôt au cinéma les et dalsa le
noël gauthier à présent avec moi en
plateau bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le
président du comité départemental de
randonnée pédestre des yvelines vous
organisé dimanche avec l'association
trop de sentiers manie quoi le rando
challenge c'est à magny les hameaux déjà
quel est le principe du rando challenge
de rando challenge est tout à fait
similaire à ce qu'on appelle relie en
voiture c'était ça ce parti que par
équipe de deux trois quatre personnes
sur un circuit déterminé les gens les
équipes reçoivent une carte sur lesquels
deux tracés déterminé à eux de lire la
carte et de parcours sensible le chemin
avec un côté ludique ils devront
répondre à des lésions qu'il ya au
patrimoine à la nature absolument ils
vont trouver sur le parcours des
questions qui sont relatives soit 2,2
que mantel sûr que deux reçu à de
l'observation le patrimoine ma nature ça
permet surtout aux équipes de découvrir
le lieu où circulent d'ailleurs with
many magny les hameaux c'est un lieu
idéal on en vallée de chevreuse c'est un
bel itinéraire pour faire de la
randonnée le parcours qu'on a retenu
sera parfait je pense avec deux parcours
un de 8 à 12 km qui est siglé découverte
un autre compétition qui fera de 12 à 18
kilomètres ça veut dire ça s'adresse à
tout le monde qu'on est qu'on ne fasse
pas de la randonnée au quotidien les
verts de découverte est ouvert à tous
les participants il ya d'ailleurs pas
mal de familles qui participent d'un
avec des enfants qui disent en aucun
problème pour faire du circuit donc pas
de soucis pour faire ce parcours 15 est
couvert en fin de parcours de choristes
et du coup le parcours compétition
alors il ya un classement ont pour le
championnat de france c'est absolument
le peu de parcours compétition sert à
donner des points au club qui sert
ensuite à un classement au niveau
national mais vous le disiez tout à
l'heure c'est ce sont des parcours qui
se foutent par l'équipe
c'est ça ce sont des patrons qui
s'effectue par équipes mal nécessite un
bon sens de l'observation
le matériel à prévoir les équipements
pour cette journée matière à prévoir
c'est évidemment de la pression il faut
pouvoir boire
éventuellement si le temps est menaçant
de quoi se couvrir
enfin coupe-vent n'importe quoi enfin
pas de parapluie c'est pas très agréable
mais de rester couvert et pour les
chaussures si je veux surtout qu'on fait
sur deux randonnées c'est recommandé
comment on y participer il faut
s'inscrire au préalable suffit de
s'inscrire sur le site du comité
départemental de la randonnée pédestre
le caudéran de 78 le site s'affiche
actuellement en bas de l'écran ça ça va
coûter combien ça coûte combien de
participer aussi j'ai bon souvenir ça de
tête 10 ou 15 euros par équipe
donc j'ai tout à fait minime et vous
retrouvez bien sûr toutes les
informations sur le site du coc des
randos 78 je voulais aussi profiter de
votre votre présence pour parler plus
généralement des randonnées pédestres
dans le département 1300 km de réseau
pédestre servi la richesse c'est c'est
quoi c'est que ce soit un des parcours
on est sur un département à cheval sur
l'urbain surnaturel c'est ça la rive est
du département
on est beaucoup plus sur le solde
naturel le sud du département quand même
très très très naturel ces chemins sont
entretenu par environ 70 baliseurs qui
entretiennent pour le chemin chaque
année c'est l'une des missions du col et
rando c'est la principale mission du
clos des randos je crois c'est
entretenir et créer des chemins ont créé
beaucoup de chemin la demande soit de
municipalités soit du conseil fonctionne
il ya beaucoup de demandeurs pour la
création de chemins et du coup les
autres missions c'est d'organiser des
sorties des autres missions sont
principalement dévolue au club il y en a
sûrement sous une cinquantaine de
résident line avec 4304 1400 adhérents
donc c'est les clubs qui organisent leur
sortie et il y en a quasiment tous les
jours on va peut-être pas vous demander
votre préférence mais on n'est pas loin
de la vallée de chevreuse on imagine ça
c'est un territoire idéal pour la
randonnée l'intérieur et des halles
toute la vallée de chevreuse il ya la
forêt de rambouillet enfin c'est c'est
très riche et les itinéraires de
randonnée sont à retrouver dans un livre
qui s'appelle les yvelines à pied qui
est disponible dans tous les points de
vente ça fait partie de te de la série
des topo guide édité par la fédération
dont celui ci les vignes pied qui
contient beaucoup de parcours très
intéressant parcourir merci noël
gaultier d'être pas ses emplettes au
président du coc des randos 78 le comité
départemental de randonnée pédestre des
yvelines et je rappelle cette date c'est
ce dimanche le rando challenge c'est à
magny les hameaux toutes les
informations à retrouver sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
avant de vous quitter la saison
culturelle du 2d l'encours est lancée
samedi dernier le prisme proposait une
journée d'activités artistiques au
programme spectacles expositions
ateliers
retour sur cette journée avec nicolas
dandy
voilà la chanson dussault qu'aucun ses
sonorités bears ce monde peuplé d'une
colonie d'oursons de l'aisne de tissus
et d'instruments de musique en bois un
univers destinés aux bébés dès l'âge de
six semaines
une expérience créée il y a neuf ans
inspirées par les voyages de soko en
asie on y trouve beaucoup c'est beaucoup
de choses qui sont fabriqués et
confectionnés à la main avec avec des
beaucoup d'objets de récupération on
retrouve énormément de sonorité assez
vibratoire du cou qui sont là pour
vraiment stimulé les les premiers émois
des tout petits
le saut cocoon c'est aussi un langage
nouveau entre les parents et leurs
nourrissons une découverte sensorielle
du toucher et de l'ouïe
c'est le cas de matisse 13 mois avec son
papa patrice je pense qu'il a passé un
bon moment où il sait d'adhérents budé
il a découvert pas mal de choses voilà
je pense que c'était un très bon moment
en famille ce spectacle vivant lance la
saison 2019-2020 du prisme elancourt une
année culturelle placée sous le signe de
la pluridisciplinarité le prisme c'est à
la fois un lieu de spectacle vivant
évidemment c'est même sa destination est
essentielle à l'origine mais nous
accueillons aussi maintenant au sein de
l'équipe tout le pôle enseignement
artistique avec l'école de musique de
danse d'arts plastiques
plusieurs activités organisées ce samedi
28 septembre dont un atelier d'arts
plastiques pour redécorer le bâtiment on
a décidé de mettre plein de couleurs sur
notre vitre avec du film adhésif
cette journée l'occasion aussi de
découvrir l'exposition cosmo 51 de
l'artiste thaddée le vernissage est
prévu le 11 octobre jour du concert de
guillaume perret au prisme
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi dans un instant retrouver
un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés manon
varaldo parlera de la méthode éducative
dolto rester avec nous c'est dans un
instant belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]